hello everyone how are you guys I'll do
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
today here with my fourth money-making
video if you guys want to see any of the
other ones some links will probably
appear on Bank done alright so this
background that I got here not intended
at all however does have to deal with
the money making method that we have
today so basically what we have today is
by dwarf canons this is really low
requirement as I believe all you need to
have done is like the dwarf cannon quest
which barely has anything done or barely
has any requirements at all to do it so
yeah this is really convenient placement
but the only thing you are going to need
is a little bit of money and yeah that's
really about it stamina potions help
Glory amulets help I'm gonna show you
guys one inventory and how much money I
made off of it before you do this though
check out the prices of cannons
basically whatever you want it what you
want to do is just go to the GE buy one
see what it's buying for realistically
you can almost always list them up for
about 775 K and yeah so you could you
could try to buy it and sell it on and
pieces but pieces don't aren't that
often bought considering you can buy
them as a set so basically as I was
saying what you're going to need you're
going to need a glory and if you're
doing multiple trips you're going to
need stamina potions as well however I'm
only going to be doing one trip so I am
going to fast-forward through this and
kind of talk over probably at the end
alright so I have a timer ready I'm
going to start it and I'm going to
teleport away so we are going to see how
long it takes me to do a trip of cannon
so basically what you want to do is
you're gonna want to follow where I'm
going so I'll pull up a map real quick
to show you guys you're gonna want to
start an edge run down through the
monastery and go to the Dwarven mine
you're gonna see this little little
building on the Left hand-side
yep you're gonna be want to be in there
so I'm going to fast forward you guys
can follow my path if you don't know how
to get there already but if you do then
yeah I guess just hold tight for a few
seconds
all right so as I was saying it is you
it does or I don't know if I said this
yet alright so as I was saying I don't
know if I've said this yet but you do
have to pay 750 K for each cannon so you
are making 25k per one and as you can
see you have to just go through some
dialogue so go to the first one I was
hoping you would sell me a cannon and
then he'll say how much 750 K okay I
will take a cannon and then he'll sell
you at for 750 k then what you have to
do which is kind of annoying is you have
to go ahead and drop all of them so he
will not give you another one if you
have one in your inventory this is where
it becomes a little dicey because if you
don't pick them up and someone does
happen to come by and start picking them
up then you're kind of screwed but you
do have I believe about a minute to
maybe two minutes and so you should be
pretty good so I'm gonna fast forward
until I have bought up an entire
inventory of cannon pieces alright so as
you can see there are some white dots on
my screen so I'm gonna go ahead and try
to pick all these things up real quick
just because I'm a little nervous about
them potentially actually being able to
get it so go ahead and redraw everything
and then buy I think you can buy six per
run so yeah go ahead and do that or you
could bring probably the exact right
amount of GP for seven and then you
could be able to actually I believe get
seven in an inventory alright so I
finished off that inventory in just
about three minutes I actually should
have had to pick up I should have been
able to pick up or buy I guess another
one however I didn't just because I
thought I already hit the my limit of
six obviously I did not and so
realistically we're going to multiply it
times six so because that's how much you
can make I didn't make that much because
I'm [__] stupid that was the first
inventory I've done in a while but I'm
gonna go put these all in two sets and
show you how much we can sell them off
for alright so as you guys can see here
we are so I bought a cannon set earlier
for 775 k and obviously I've been buying
these for 750 that would make it so that
we are making 25k per one I'm just going
to go ahead and pack all of these and
I'm not gonna list them up cuz I have a
secret item up in my GE but basically I
made 125k in three minutes you should be
able to make a hundred and fifty and so
with that being said with I guess you
can
so you could do 20 of these trips per
hour right 150 or 3 minutes times 20 60
minutes so if you make 150 K per
inventory and you do 20 trips an hour
that is literally 3 mil an hour now the
one thing you do have to be careful of
is you're obviously going to have a mass
amount of canned sets if you do that
you're going to have a ton of them and
so you'll just be keeping down the price
if you do this for hours on end and they
will never go up above that price until
all of yours of solds I'd recommend
doing this in like an hour day or an
hour every other day kind of thing this
is every now and then money making
method so it's still around but
obviously you can do what you want
there is one recommendation before I get
to the outro though that I would
recommend for you guys now having
alternate accounts in some instances are
very helpful I believe this is one of
them because if you have an alt account
and you drop the cannon sets you never
have to worry about actually picking
back up the cannon sets if you're in a
world that's empty you could have an alt
account standing under that and
constantly picking up the cannon sets
and running while you're actually just
buying them on your main which could
make for a very very profitable very
profitable [__] method alright so I
hope you guys enjoyed the video if you
guys did feel free to hit that like
button if you guys have anything that I
can improve upon feel free to comment
and tell me about it down below if you
guys really enjoyed the video I want to
see more of these in the future or any
of my older videos feel free to hit that
subscribe button and yeah there will be
it there be a Twitter thing in the
description hit up the Twitter the
Twitter's the Twitter needs some love
but yeah nonetheless with that being
said hope you guys have a wonderful day
and peace